So, I'm going to provide a start on this code and now
we'll leave the crucial part of it for you to do as
a quiz. You should feel free at any point to stop
and try to figure out more of the code on your own.
There are lots of different ways to do this and we'll
show you one. And you'll finish that as a quiz. So, the
first thing we're going to do is define two constants. So, we're
going to use d as the damping factor. And I'll use 0.8 as
my damping factor. That's the probability, thinking about
our random web surfer, that she selects the link
on the current page, rather than starting over with
a new random page. The other constant I'm going to
define here we'll call numloops. That's the number of
times we're going to go through the relaxation. What we're
computing is the value of rank at some time
step. The number of times we go through that
is going to determine the accuracy of our ranks. We'll
use ten as the number of loops. You can experiment with
changing that, and one of the questions in the homework
assignment will ask you to think about what happens when you
change that. So, now we need to start, we said
initially the rank of each url is 1 divided by the
number of pages and so the dictionary ranks, we want to initialize
with those values. So, we are going to create an empty dictionary.
We'll call it ranks. The number of pages, the number of
pages, we can get from the graph. The graph is a
dictionary of nodes and len of graph will tell us the
number of entries in that dictionary. So, that's the number of
nodes in the graph which is the number of pages that
we've crawled. And now we want to go through the pages
initializing each page to the value one divided by npages, and
I'm remembering to use 1.0 here to make sure the division
is done as floating point division and we get an
accurate number rather than integer division. So, now, we've
initialized the ranks. We have a dictionary that maps each
page to its current rank, which is one divided by
the number of pages. So, now, we get to the
interesting part. We need a loop that's going to go through
the number of times of numloops. Each time through this
loop, what we want to do is update the newranks
based on this formula, using the old ranks. And then, at
the end of the loop, we are going to make the variable
ranks hold what was previous newranks and that way, we
can keep going, each time we are going to get a new value
from newranks. At the end of doing all updates, we are
going to update ranks to refer to whatever newranks is. So, that
means each time through this loop we are going to create
a new dictionary called newranks that starts as empty, and we're going
to add all the pages to newranks as we update
their rank. So, to do that we need to go through
the pages in the graph and for each page what we
want to do is compute the new rank for that page.
And the first thing we'll do is this part. The
new rank is 1 minus d divided by npages plus this
summation. So, the first thing we will do is introduce a
new variable, we will call it newrank and we will assign
it to this value. Then we are going to update it as
we go through the pages that link into this page. So, we'll
start by initializing newrank as 1 minus d divided by the number
of pages. So, then what we need to do is update for this
summation. And I'm going to leave this blank. And I'm going to
skip that for now. This is going to be left as a
quiz. We'll finish the rest of the code. And then your quiz
will be to finish this part of the code, which is really the
most interesting part of computing the page ranks. Once
we've done that, so we've used newrank as a variable
to keep track of the rank for this page.
Well, we want to update our dictionary, so we're going
to add an entry, newranks. We're still within the
for loop, you're going to put your code that sums
up all the links here. Once we've done that, we've
got the value of newrank that reflects both the probability
of starting from that page, and the popularity from all
the inlinks. And so, we'll update this to be newrank. We've
added that to our dictionary, so once we've finished looping through
all the pages in the graph, well now, we're ready for
the next step. So, that means, we want to make the
variable ranks refer to the newranks, so we've changed the
time step to the next time step, and now we're going to
go back through this loop, and we go through this loop,
number of loops times, each time we're
updating the ranks, and when we're done, what
we want to return is ranks. That's the
dictionary that maps each page to its rank.